[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم في اليوم الثالث لعيد
العرش اكثر من 1400 مستوطن يقتحمون باحات
الاقصى شرطه الاحتلال تعتدي على المرابطين
وتعتقل عددا منهم والخارجيه الفلسطينيه
تنددد بمحاولات اسرائيل لتقسيم المسجد
مكانيا وحماس تدعو لتصعيد المواجهه كوسوفو
تتهم بلغراد بالتخطيط بهجمات وتقول ان
الجيش الصربي درب منفذي الهجوم الذي
استهدف قوه امنها قبل ايام ووزيره
خارجيتها تقول ان نشر صربيا قواتها يذكر
بسلوك روسيا تجاه اوكرانيا قبل الغزو
والنيتو يعلن انه سينشر نحو 600 جندي
بريطاني في كوسوفو 26 اصابه في حريق ضخم
بمبنى مديريه امن الاسماعيليه شمال شرق
القاهره النيابه العامه المصريه تقول ان
الحريق اسفر عن تفحم كامل المبنى وتع فتح
تحقيق تحت شعار صحراء خضراء بيئه افضل
معرض اكسبو الدوحه 2023 ينطلق اليوم في
قطر بمشاركه 80 دوله ويقاوم لاول مره في
دوله ذات مناخ صحراوي يتضمن فعاليات
وتظاهرات كبرى وورش عمل لابتكار حلول على
الصعيد العالمي لمشاكل التصحر والتغير
المناخي وتحديات الاستدامه الى
اللقاء y